Kleiner Zusammenschnitt von Björn 13. Vielen Dank, Moment, Björn 13, weil du es so benannt hast, weil es der 13. Björn. Wir sind mittlerweile bei 13 Björns angekommen. Kein Max, aber 13 Björns. Kein Max, aber 13 Björns. Alle Björns könnten ein satanistisches Ritual vollführen, indem sie sich zu 13 treffen. Guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von das Podcast UFO. Schönen guten Tag, Florentin, hallo. Ja, das war Stefan Tietze, schön, dass ihr seine Stimme erkennt jedes Mal. Ihr wisst es immer schon, bevor ich es sage, ihr ruft es laut aus, ihr meldet euch, schnippt mit der Finger in der Hand, aber dann sage ich es trotzdem noch, er ist immer... Okay, willkommen nochmal rein. Das war's. Vorher haben wir doch gesagt, das sollten wir mit zwischen nach 519 Folgen wissen, abhusten. Ja, das stimmt, du hast recht, nein. Ich habe nicht viel geschlafen diese Nacht, ich habe wild geträumt, ich hatte zu viel Anspruch, ich hatte zu viel vor, ich habe mir zu viel vorgenommen in der Nacht. Du kannst niemals bei WDR 2 die Morgenscheu übernehmen, wo du schon um 4.30 Uhr, hallo, hallo Sektor, wie geht's euch, mir geht's super, ich hab neunzehn Kaffees in Tos. Und du bist eher so, jetzt, obwohl wir mitten am Tag haben, hallo. Guten Morgen, seid ihr schon wach, warum, was ist los, wir gucken uns die neuesten Trends an, Service, wie kriegt ihr bessere Snacks im Flugzeug? Leute, ich bin müde, ihr seid müde, ihr habt keinen Bock auf die Arbeit, ich hab keinen Bock auf die Arbeit, so, jetzt kommt ihr, jetzt kommt hier ein Song und dann kommt so ein mega happy, life is the highway, all my long, kommt so ein mega geiler Song, aber man ist so mega angepisst.
Nee, ich hatte eine komplette To-Do-Liste im Schlaf irgendwie.
Ich wollte Erholung, ich wollte Schlaf, ich wollte Träume.
Du wolltest mal wieder zu viel von der Nacht.
Ich wollte zu viel, ich wollte Sprachen lernen.
Ich habe ja diese Sprachlernkassetten, die nebenbei laufen,
wo man immer so schön ein paar Französisch-Vokabeln nebenbei noch reingeballert bekommt ins Gehirn.
Und das war zu viel. Ich glaube, es war zu viel.
Ich habe mir zu viel vorgenommen und mein Körper hat gesagt, nee, ich brauche jetzt auch mal Ruhe. Und dann gab es so einen Shutdown oder war das so ein anstrengendes, nerviges, dein Kopf rotiert und du rutscht langsam in den Schlaf. Genau, der Kopf rotiert, YouTube-Kommentare, wieder Hallen in den leeren Hallen meines Gehirns, immer hin und her. Man muss sich so vorstellen, du bist wie so ein Simpsons-Character, der dann so im Bett sich immer umdreht und so, aber eigentlich schläft. Aber trotzdem, es wird schon. Ich habe vier Marte-Intros, ich glaube, das ist gut. Und natürlich auch vielen, vielen Dank an Max, der die Vorherrschaft der Max-Intros wieder zurück erringen möchte und hier einen, wie ich finde, sehr präzisen, aber auch angebrachten Schuss gegen die Björns dieser Welt gesetzt hat. Das war sehr präzise, das war klar. Da hat er den Pfeil und Bogen in die Hand genommen und hat auf die Björns gezielt und ich würde sagen getroffen. Er hat nicht nur getroffen, er hat den Pfeil in der Mitte halbiert, er hat wirklich zwei Björns gleichzeitig ausgeschaltet. Zwei Björns gleichzeitig ausgeschaltet mit seinem messerscharfen Verstand und treffsicherer Kunstfertigkeit. Treffer versenkt. Sehr gut gemacht Max. Gut gemacht, weiter so. Max acht war das übrigens, der achte Max, also aktuell acht Max gegen dreizeörns, könnt ihr gerne euch in der WG-Party fragen, wer würde gewinnen acht Max gegen 13 Björns, kann man gerne mal durchspielen mit der WG. Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß, wer gewinnt. Wir alle wissen, wer gewinnt. Wir alle wissen, wer gewinnt. Ganz im Ernst, ich bin mir so sicher, weil manchmal machen Namen, machen Menschen, bin ich mir der festen Überzeugung. Gibt's da nicht auch noch, habe ich da nicht mal was gelesen, weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich lese zu viel, habe zu viel Wissen in meinem Kopf, was sich verdrängt und gegenseitig rauskegelt und am Ende bleibt nichts über. Ja, ich habe auch mal von so einer Studie gelesen, dass Leute relativ gut vorhersagen können, welche Namen Leute haben. Stimmt, du kannst erkennen. Aber könnte auch auf einer Cornflakespackung nicht. Nee, nee, nee, es gibt eine Studie, du kannst anhand von Bildern erkennen, wie Namen heißen. Die Chance ist größer. Nee, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir. Und deswegen kannst du nämlich durch mit dem Stefan zeichen. Anstatt Gegenargumente zu dir von Knurrig, einfach nur, wenn du was missbäht. Nee, und ich sage laut, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir. So diskutieren wir heute. Glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, glaub mir, bitte, glaub mir, glaub mir. Ja, okay. Aber die Idee ist, dass die Eltern checken, wie das Kind ist und das richtigen Namen geben? Oder ist die Idee, dass das Kind unter dem Namen so wächst, wie das sein soll mit dem Namen? Ich sag mal, allein sowas wie Haarfarbe, Hautfarbe, gibt ja schon manchmal gewisse Namen.
Haarfarbe?
Mit sich, ja. Wenn du jetzt, wenn du eine...
Blondie oder was?
Wenn du A, also wie heißt diese Person, du hast oben ein Blondschopf und es ist A, Mert, B, Ludwig Son, C, Rachel oder D, Satan ist, dann weisst du ja wahrscheinlich, wie der Mensch heisst. Und ich glaube, jetzt mal ganz plakativ gesagt, es geht ja nicht darum, dass die 100 Prozent der Stimmen bekommen, sondern dass man quasi mehrheitlich den Namen herausfinden kann. Eher. Spannend wird es natürlich bei Jasper, Jensen, Björn und Jörn. Das wäre natürlich dann interessant. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Wahrscheinlich ja, wahrscheinlich werden die den Test nicht besonders einfach gemacht haben, sondern einigermassen valide, empirisch belegbar. Aber ich habe eine ganz, ganz klare Tendenz. Bei acht Max gegen dreizehn Björns habe ich eine richtig klare Tendenz. Aber du sprichst sie nicht aus. Doch, bei null, auf der gedachten Null sagen wir beide, wer gewinnt. Okay. Drei, zwei. Die gedachte Null. Muss ich die Null auch denken oder reicht es, wenn du sie denkst? Es reicht, wenn ich die denke. Okay. Nee, wobei, du musst ja auch was sagen. Ich muss mitdenken. Du musst mitdenken. Okay. Drei, zwei, eins, Max. Na klar. Naja, na ja, warum? Warum acht Max? Es sind vier Björns weniger. Max ist ja der ... Als Max musst du dich ja eh schon durchsetzen in der Gesellschaft mehr, weil es mehr Maxes gibt. Ach so, je häufiger der Name ist, desto mehr muss man kämpfen, um individuell zu sein. Ich verstehe. In unseren Breitengraden geht es ja um Individualismus, vor allem erstmal. In Peru nicht, oder? Nicht um Konformität. In Peru ist noch was ganz anderes, da könnte ich jetzt lange ausholen und geschichtlich, da müsste ich jetzt bei... Cool, nee, das macht immer Spaß, fremde Kulturen zu erleben. Blickt man ganz andere auf seine eigene. Ich weiss ungefähr, was ich meine. Max musst früh die Ellenbogen ausfahren. Oder ist es so ein bisschen aggressiverer Name? Wohingegen ich, der einen unkonventionellen Namen hat, ich war einfach komplett segelfrei durchs Leben, musste mich nie durchsetzen, weil allein durch meinen Namen war ich schon was Besonderes und konnte allein dadurch schon punkten. Du hast recht. Genau. Ich bin schwach. Ich bin aber auch schwach. Ich bin ganz weich. Nein, ein bisschen nicht, ich bin nicht bisschen nicht. Ich bin weich. Du bist weich, aber du bist nicht schwach. Ich habe letztens, und da schäme ich mich wirklich dafür, mal wieder versucht, joggen zu gehen, und es war die absolute Katastrophe. Es war wirklich die absolute Katastrophe. Ich bin zum Rhein gegangen und ich ... Du bist zum Rhein gegangen. So, nee, nee,
da fängt es ab, wie schon neunzehn.
Ja, soll ich mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren oder was?
Nein, joggen! Nee, das geht nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, du musst,
ich muss mich mental überhaupt erst auf das
Konzept Bewegung einstellen. Ich muss erst
irgendwo hingehen. Kannst du den Part nicht zu Hause machen.
Nee, nee, nee, ich muss erst irgendwo hingehen,
da jogge ich auch nicht und dann geht's los
und ich lüge dich nicht an, wenn ich sage, ich war durchgeschwitzt, als ich dort ankam, noch bevor ich angefangen habe.
Es war wahnsinnig heiß, ich sah aus wie einfach so ein Schlafanzugmensch, einfach gleiche Farbe der Hose wie T-Shirt, völlig falsch gewählt. Vorher schon. Und dann habe ich aber zum Joggen nämlich ja nicht mein Handy mit, sondern einen alten iPod, wo ich eigentlich dachte, ich hätte coole Joggingmusik draufgeladen, als ich dann aber dastand. Love is a highway all night long. Das zeigt sich, dass das nicht der Fall war. Und die einzige Playlist, die ich runtergeladen hatte, war Romantische Balladen. So, und jetzt, und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das kam, in welchem Zustand, Gemütszustand ich das letzte Mal diesen iPod in der Hand hatte. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie Liebeskummer-Retreat oder so. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, fuck, damit muss ich jetzt arbeiten. Aber so ein monothematischer iPod, also so, wo man sagt, ich brauche darauf wirklich nur, und da muss ich mich selbst konditionieren, dass ich nicht auf die Idee komme, ein bisschen was härteres oder gut gelautes zu hören. Ich will, dass auch die komplette Shuffle-Playlist nur Songs bietet, die jetzt gerade passen, romantische Balladen. Und dann bin ich da losgejoggt, irgendwie zu Ceele, zu Alicia Keys, irgendwie viel R'n'B, viel gefühlig und währenddessen nicht ... Einfach furchtbar, absolut katastrophal und es ist ja lächerlich, wie schnell man und viel man abbaut. Das ist, glaube ich, das Schlimmste am Menschsein, ist, dass Dinge, die man geschafft hat, auch wieder weg sind relativ schnell. Du lernst ein Stück auf dem Klavier, nach zwei Wochen nichts mehr da. Und du denkst dir, was soll das? Joggen, ich konnte mal die ganze Strecke joggen, ich habe da so einen Weg hin und zurück, jetzt habe ich die Hälfte von hin geschafft. Viertel, 25 Prozent, 75 Prozent sind weg. Was ist denn das für ein Kurs? Ja, das ist scheiße. Das ist richtig, also was soll, sorry, aber da ist es dann auch irgendwann auch nicht mehr meine Schuld, dass ich keinen Sport mache, wenn das der Kurs ist. Ja, vor allem, und dann kommen, wir spüren mal ein paar Folgen zurück, wo ich hier gesagt habe, sollten nicht alle Tiere so gut angepasst sein wie der Mensch, sollten nicht alle Tiere genauso clever und cool und fit sein, survival of the fittest, wir sind fucking unangepasst, wir sind so doof, wir sind so bescheuert, wir halten uns nur noch so barely selbst am Leben und selbst das läuft nicht gut. Ja und selbst das irgendwie, alle Rückenschmerzen fallen unter ihrem eigenen Gewicht zusammen, die halten nicht mal was hoch, sondern das eigene Gewicht ist schon zu viel.
Irgendwann ist auch, glaube ich, einfach so Schneckenmodus evolutionär angesagt, dass wir einfach so einen Molassehaufen, weil wir brauchen auch keine Knochen irgendwann mehr und Muskeln, wir sind einfach nur noch so ein Schleimhaufen auf dem Boden. Also ich dachte, irgendwann kommt diese Käseglocke mit dem Gehirn drin und gut ist.
Also, aber das ist spannend, weil ich finde, also zum einen, wenn du das wegen Abnehmen Gründen machst, dann lauf doch einfach, also nicht joggen, sondern eh einfach sehr viel. Ich bin den Rest der Strecke gegangen, immer mit im Hintergrund, ja, gleich jogge ich wieder los. Ich war so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das vom Breakdance kennt, dieser Move, bevor man wirklich reinbrakt, so dieses so, meine über Kreuz hin und her, so. Und in diesem, okay, gleich ist es los, Mann, gleich ist's los, wow, das wird krass, gleich geht's los, Mann, wuh, Alter, gleich geht's los, und das über Minuten und Stunden. Also wirklich nur in diesem, gleich jogg ich los, also dieses Gehen mit diesem, gleich geht's los, aber es geht nie los. So war ich am Rhein unterwegs. Falls ihr mich gesehen habt, es war das Gamescom-Wochenende, das unfassbar dumm war, weil ich am nächsten Tag brutale Muskelkater hatte, obwohl ich mich vielleicht sieben Minuten lang bewegt habe, wirklich. Es war eine absolute Katastrophe. Nie wieder. Du lügst vor allem, finde ich, die Passanten um dich herum an. Ja. Weil du weißt, du willst nicht mehr joggen, aber deine Körperhaltung sagt, nee, ich habe nur gerade eine Restingpause, alles gut. Aber ist das nicht unter Spaziergängern ein wirklich seltener Anblick, Jogger, die gerade anfangen zu joggen? Ja genau, das habe ich auch gedacht. Ist das nicht so wie so ein Shiny-Pokémon, dass man sagt, ach Garte, du rätst nie, was wir heute beim Spaziergang gesehen haben. Ein Jogger, der gerade angefangen hat zu joggen. Genau, Babytauben sind genauso wie anzufangene Jogger oder so Mikrowellen, die genau auf Null sind, wenn man hingeht. Oder entende Jogger auch. Entende Jogger, die dann... Das ist ein ganz trauriger Anblick, die dann zum Stehen kommen. Und die einen Schlüssel aus der Tasche kamen und dann war die ganze Zeit ein Schlüssel in deiner Tasche. Das heißt, dein Joggen war die ganze Zeit ein Klimper, Klimper, Klimper, Klimper, Klimper. Ja, merkwürdig, habe ich auch noch nie gesehen. Jogger, die angefangen haben, habe ich einmal im Leben gesehen. Wirklich. Aber es kommt einem so doof vor, wenn man selber anfängt zu joggen. Deswegen mache ich es auch nicht. Nee, ich mache das immer, ich ziehe mich in so eine dunkle Gasse zurück oder in so ein Gebüsch und daraus starte ich dann, wie so ein Sprinter bei der Olympiade, ganz versteckt, hinten unten da schön neben der vollgekotzten Buschleiche da, sitze ich da und dann sprinke ich los. Bei den brennenden Fässern, bei den brennenden Ölfässern, den Streunerkatzen und dem Jungen, der geschrien hat, ich habe gesehen, wie du ihn gefangen hast, und du sagst, nein! Und den drei Blue-Man-Group-Leuten, die da auf den Mülltonnen da spielen, und ich einfach mittendrin und zack, zack, zack, zack. Und oben, siehst du, wenn du in den Himmel guckst, ist Batman-Logo. Ja, ja. Ich laufe extra nach Gotham, um zu joggen. Ich bin extra unterwegs. Bus nach Gotham. Und es war lächelig. A23 nach Bottrop. Okay, direkt weiter nach Gotham. Und es war wirklich so, du kennst es ja, wenn das T-Shirt die Farbe verfärbt, wenn man schwitzt. Mein T-Shirt hat am Ende vollständig die andere Farbe. Super. Es passt also wieder. Super, super. Ein Betrachter von außen denkt, der schwitzt überhaupt nicht.
Der schwitzt gar nicht. Der rennt hier, aber
ordentlich flott, kann man sagen.
Er trägt ein nasses Shirt, denkt man vielleicht.
Er kommt von einem Wet-T-Shirt-Contest gerade.
Kann sein, würde passen,
aber er schwitzt überhaupt nicht. Meine Idee war,
und jetzt
möchte ich, dass er das umsetzt da draußen,
liebe, und jetzt eine Gruppe,
an die ich mich selten wende, liebe Architekturfreunde, Architekten, Architektinnen. Die wachen endlich mal wieder auf. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ohurfreunde, Architekten, Architektinnen. Die wachen endlich mal wieder auf. Oh, oh, oh, Leute, es gibt was zu tun, es gibt was zu tun. Dann rutschen die an ihren Stangen runter. Ihren sehr elaborierten Stangen einfach wenden. Ja, die nicht so pragmatisch sind, sondern eher ungünstig. Das fällt aber jetzt erst auf. So, nämlich, weil ich hätte eine Idee, ähnlich zu deinem Shirt, was eine andere Farbe bekommt, wenn es nass wird, wie wäre es denn, weil Regen macht Menschen ja eher tendenziell ein bisschen unglücklich. Jetzt gerade nicht, weil es lange Dürre war, freut man sich auch fast wieder über das Gefühl, man weiß gar nicht mehr, wie riecht denn der Regen, Sommerregen ist ja auch was Schönes. Ich meine eher so in einer dunkleren Jahreszeit, wo es die ganze Zeit matschig und dunkel ist. Und da finde ich nämlich schön, wenn Häuser Farben so wären, dass wenn Regen draufkommt, sie eine andere Farbe einnehmen. Zum Beispiel bunter werden. Buntere Farben. Zum Beispiel bunter werden, dachte ich jetzt. Also, dass sie zum Beispiel so ein knallig, also dass die eigentlich grau sind, so so ein hässliches Grau im Sommer und dann plötzlich kommt ein Regenschauer runter und dann werden die so bunt. Strahlend türkis oder ein tolles Sommergelb oder regenbogenbunt. Okay. Und du meinst, die Leute würden dann sagen, ach, es regnet zwar, aber was für schöne Farben in meiner Sicht. Nee, ich hätte nur versucht, einen künstlerischen Überbau dafür zu finden, dass man Farben benutzt, die die Farbe ändern, wenn sie nass werden. Das finde ich einfach gut. Ich glaube, braucht das nicht, dass es dann glücklicher ist. Ich finde es einfach cool, wenn Farben anders sind. Jetzt kommt dein ketzerischer Ausspruch, werden die Farben nämlich ein bisschen anders, wird es nicht dunkelgrau, wenn dann... Nee, ich überleg halt nur, was passiert, wenn das Haus schwitzt. Weil ist es dann nicht noch unangenehmer, wenn das Haus anfängt zu schwitzen und alle anderen Häuser sehen sofort, dass du schwitzt, weil du knalltürkis bist und alle so Hä, es regnet doch gar nicht, Rudi, Rudi, es regnet doch gar nicht. Ja, ich weiß, ja, ich weiß. Ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe ein bisschen, ich stehe ja hier auch mit der Ostseite zu. Oh Gott, ich kann nicht mehr.
Häuser schwitzen nicht, Häuser schwitzen nicht über die Zunge.
Was wissen Sie doch alle?
Aber sind Häuser überhaupt von außen bemalt mit Farbe?
Klaro, klaro Kiste.
Nee, guck mal, da ist hier ja einfach Steine.
Ja, hier haben wir jetzt ein paar Steinhäuser und ein paar mit diesem hässlichen Braun,
dieses Kölner Vermieter, wir geben Scheiße auf die Farbe unserer Häuser. Wir lassen es einfach so, wie es ist. Wie teuer soll die Farbe sein? Nö, dann lassen wir es, wie sähe es denn aus, wenn man das einfach weglässt? So sehen alle Häuser ja hier aus. Manche sind weiss gestrichen, hier das ist gelb gestrichen dies Jahr. Und wir haben euch ein neues Puzzlestück gegeben zur grossen Frage, wo nehmen wir auf? Ich habe gehört, es gibt schon einige Hörerinnen und Hörer, die haben ein Spezialkomitee, ein Ortungskomitee zusammengestellt. Wir geben hier hinweise Tipps vor zwei Folgen, große Beschwerdewelle, dass Kirchenglocken zu hören waren. Aber andere Leute haben das als nervig angesehen. Manche haben sich aber auch ganz genau notiert, die Frequenzen, die Verzögerungen, Doppler-Effekt, wie schnell bewegt sich unser Aufnahmeort und all das, da kann man eine Menge Informationen rausziehen und ich glaube, noch ein paar. Wie schnell bewegt sich unser Aufnahmeort, okay. Ja, warum nicht, wir können ja auch mobil aufnehmen. Genau, mein Tipp wäre noch, also kein Tipp, aber eine Erklärung zu den Kirchenglocken, eigentlich nehmen wir immer, ist ein bisschen langweilig, finde ich, wenn Podcasterinnen darüber erzählen, wo sie aufnehmen. Ich will es trotzdem kurz mal eben machen. Und zwar, wir beginnen so meistens so um elf Uhr aufzunehmen und um zwölf Uhr beginnen die Kirchenglocken, hier Ramwazamba zu machen, aber natürlich zur denkbar döfsten Zeit, weil es länger können Kirchenglocken nicht läuten am Stück. Und ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich lustig, wenn diese Kirchenglocken uns immer an das Ende der Folge erinnern.
Das stimmt, wenn ihr schon immer wisst, oh, jetzt sind die Glocken, jetzt geht es gleich zu Ende.
Das ist gleich zu Ende.
Das ist wie so ein Outro-Musik eigentlich. Von Gott. Von Gott.
Apropos langweilige Podcasts an Gewohnheiten. Wir haben Post bekommen.
Und zwar im Reddit wurdest du hingewiesen, denn unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer sind natürlich auch manchmal unsere Assistenten und Gehilfen und vor allem unsere lebenden Wecker.
Ja, denn wir haben keine Wecker, wir haben ein ganz schlechtes Zeitgefühl und deswegen brauchen wir manchmal eure Hilfe und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank an SouthStrawberry2231, der im Reddit folgenden Post gestellt hat, um dich zu erinnern, nämlich Stephans Pseudo-Ephedrinsucht. Erinnerung, Pseudo-Ephedrin, Stefan möchte es nur noch bis September 2022 nehmen, UFO 218 Minuten 44, 35 Sekunden, erbitte Update. Stefan, was hat es damit auf sich, konnten wir dich hier gerade noch mal vor einer schweren Medikamentensucht bewahren?
Ich musste lange überlegen, woher denn das kommt, die Geister, die ich rief, weil ich glaube nämlich, dass ich nie wirklich Pseudoephydrin abhängige. Ich erinnere mich wohl mal, dass ich Allergietabletten primär aus dem Grund genommen habe, weil in einer ist Pseudoephydrin drin, um gegen das Zetirizin zu wirken, das eigentliche Antiallergikum, was aber ermüdend wirkt. Also hat man sich gesagt, komm, wir machen da auch 50 Prozent Pseudoephydrin rein, damit man wieder cool drauf ist. Okay. Das ist übrigens das, was Walter White am Anfang der ersten Folgen von Breaking Bad sucht, Pseudo, braucht er nämlich für seinen Meth. Das ist nämlich ein, es nagelt mich nicht darauf fest, ein Metamphetamin, ein Amphetamin, was einen so ein bisschen pusht. Okay. So, das habe ich dann vor allem genommen in diesen Allergietabletten, da ich aber hier in Köln tatsächlich gar keine Allergieprobleme mehr habe, wo ich jetzt schon sehr lange meine Sommer verbringe, ist es gar kein Problem mehr. Nee, ich benutze kein ... Ich hab kein ... Stefan ist sauber! Hört mich an! Stefan ist sauber, du bist weggekommen, herstlichen Glückwunsch! Pseudo-Ephidrin frei seit ... Tja, seit ... Seit ... Seit ... ... fast 115 Folgen. Genau. Sehr gut, herstlichen Glückwunsch. Bin ich von Rosse gekommen, dafür massiv
Kokainabhängig. Ja gut, aber das gehört ja.
Also in der Podcasterbranche ist das ja
quasi, kommt das ja mit dem Kondensatormikrofon,
wird das mitgeliefert.
Dann liegt das in der Packung bei.
Das glaube ich jetzt nicht.
Was meint ihr, aus welchem Material
der Podcastpreis ist? Das ist schon was. Aber alte Menschen machen so Witze. Ja. Dann wird immer was wiederholt und es wird nicht besser. Es wird dann immer quasi leicht abgeändert und dann ist der Lacher nochmal ähnlich laut.
Finde ich aber auch gut. Man hat da was gefunden und man möchte es nochmal in neues Licht stellen. Ich finde das immer schön. Ich lache da immer gerne mit. Bei jedem einzelnen neuen, leicht abgeänderten Versuch. Ich versuche aber jedes Mal mit einer leicht anderen Lache zu lachen.
Einmal eher so, und dann manchmal denke ich mir, wie viel Zeit kann zwischen den einzelnen Lachimpulsen vergehen? So ein Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha! Irgendwann ist es zu viel. Ich gucke immer so, wie lange kann man es auszunehmen. Also nutzt du diese Momente, die ja eigentlich der beste Feldversuch sind für deine Marktforschung, um herauszufinden, wie weird kann ich lachen, ohne dass es jetzt sofort die Stimmung merkwürdig macht, ohne dass du auffliegst. Ha! Ha! Ja, es geht nicht. Ha! Das ist zu lang. Je mehr Pause dazwischen liegt, desto mehr müsste auch die Lautstärke des nächsten Lachers abnehmen.
Ach so.
Also mit mehr Zeit zwischen den Lachimpulsen müsste es wieder lang sein. Ja, und auch die Höhe. Genau. Ha, ha, ha. Und dann so, ha, ha. Das war ich mittlerweile das Ziel des Gags. Was hat er gesagt?
Was hat er gesagt?
Man lacht ja oft mit.
Ich lache nicht oft mit, nein.
Nee, ich bin ja ganz zockiert.
Ja, du guckst einfach immer nur verwirrt und schockiert, während alle anderen sich...
Könnt ihr das noch mal wiederholen?
Nimm mal Entschuldigung, ich habe es nicht...
Sorry.
Ich habe es akustisch nicht...
Könnt ihr kurz aufhören zu lachen?
Ja, muss wahnsinnig lustig gewesen sein.
Ganz kurz, könnt ihr nur einmal kurz sagen, ich habe es akustisch nicht verstanden. Akustisch nicht verstanden. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry! Du stehst immer ganz außen in der Gruppe und kriegst immer nicht ganz mit, worüber gelacht wird. Bringt mich zum Thema Dinner-Partys. Oh ja. Bei Dinner-Partys ... Lecker, aber nervig. Lecker, aber nervig, sozial nicht sehr einfach zu handeln, vor allem wenn ihr so soziale Overthinker seid, wie wir das sind. Man muss nämlich bei Dinnerpartys strategisch gut sitzen. Sitzt du ganz außen oder vor Kopf, mag das vielleicht ein guter Platz sein, um mal eben beim Klo zu verschwinden oder rauszugehen oder was auch immer. Du bist nur ein bisschen weit Abschrumpfschuss. Das ist ja vor allem auch ... Also Dinnerparty ist eine Sache, aber auch so Restaurants. Und das ist wirklich Fressen oder Gefressen werden. Wenn eine Gruppe von zehn Leuten ins Restaurant geht und man einigt sich auf den Tisch, dann ist wirklich nochmal urinstinkthaftes. Seit früher da, seit früher hin. Aber du weißt ja nicht, wo du, weil vor allem du darfst dich ja auch nicht als erstes hinsetzen, weil sonst setzen sich vielleicht die langweiligen Leute zu dir. Und du musst ja erst gucken, du willst ja erst, dass sich ein paar Leute hinsetzen, damit man schon so evaluieren kann, ah, das wird eher der interessante Problem. Problem, du musst so schnell. Dann musst du dich hinsetzen. Du musst so schnell sein, aber nicht zu schnell. Du darfst auch nicht zu schnell handeln. Das ist wirklich ein ganz spezieller Zeitpunkt, wo du genau deine Entscheidung treffen musst und dann so, ach so willst du da, ach so. Du hast schon recht, also es gibt Problematiken, also es gibt verschiedene Problematiken und viele Dynamiken in solchen Gruppen. Nehmen wir mal als Beispiel einer Zehnergruppe, die schauen uns, dass da zwei, drei Leute dabei sind, die den Abend nicht schmeißen, sondern eher reaktiv sind, die eben auch coole Sachen zu erzählen, auch cool, mögen die auch. Mögen wir auch. Wir mögen euch. Weil du gerade langweiler gesagt hast. Okay, sagen wir mal, wir sind alle gut befreundet, das sind vielleicht eher reaktive, passive Leute, die nicht introvertiert sind. Bei Freunden gibt es ja gute und schlechte Mischungen. Nicht jeder ist ja mit jedem auf eine gleiche Art befreundet. Es gibt ja schlechte Mischungen einfach. Aber diese drei, die wollen wir natürlich vermeiden, dass sie nah an dir sitzen. Dann gibt es aber auch coole Menschen, interessante Menschen, extrovertierte Menschen, die auch so einen Abend schmeissen können, die allerdings dazu neigen, Parallelgespräche anzufangen. Wenn du vor Kopf sitzt und du hast Parallelgespräch, Mensch A, links oder rechts oder rechts neben dir sitzen, bist du für den Abend raus. Dann fragt man dich am Montag, warum warst du beim Essen nicht dabei? Du sagst, du warst doch, ich war doch dabei. Und die sagen, was? Ja, weil du abgeschnitten warst vom Rest des Tisches. Weil jemand, weil immer neben dir ein Parallelgespräch anfängt. Diese Leute musst du eigentlich taktisch platzieren, irgendwo in der Mitte des Tisches, damit es gar nicht dazu kommen kann. Weißt du, was ich letztens erlebt habe, und das hat mich völlig irritiert, so neue soziale Bewegungen oder Momente, wo ich wirklich absolut nicht wusste, was hier passiert. Jeder kennt die Situation des klassischen Kreuzgesprpräch. Ja, Leute, zwei Gespräche werden über Kreuz geführt, es ist nervig. Und in dem Moment hat einer, der daneben saß, neben dem Vierer gespannt, dass dieses Kreuzgespräch wird, meinte so, sag mal, wollt ihr beiden euch nicht einfach umsetzen? Das habe ich auch schon mal erlebt. Also wirklich mit so einem Social Hack, so einem Regisseur-Move, der sagt, oh, ich habe hier ein Problem erkannt, wollt ihr euch nicht einfach umsetzen? Und ganz unangenehm, weil man kann das schlecht ablehnen, so, nee, schon okay. Aber in dem Moment, in dem man sich umsetzt, werden die Gespräche plötzlich richtig unangenehm. Weil man so ein richtiges Okay jetzt... Man hat einen Scheinwerfer aufs Gespräch. Genau, so, ah, wir führen jetzt ein Gespräch. Ah, anscheinend habt ihr sowas Wichtiges zu besprechen, dass ihr euch jetzt lieber mal darüber setzt und das gemeinsam diskutiert. Und es ist genau das passiert, die beiden haben sich umgesetzt und beide Gespräche flauten sofort ab. Und dann war so dieser Moment des Setzen wir uns jetzt wieder zurück? Oder ein, ach Gott, das war so schockend! Ich war da als Beobachter und wirklich ein Mineralwasser nach dem anderen geäxt, weil ich mich da irgendwie rausziehen wollte. Ganz unangenehm. Da müsste man eigentlich sagen, der Regisseur müsste dann eigentlich sagen, okay, es läuft gerade gar nicht mehr, wollt ihr euch nicht mehr zurücksetzen. Ah, dann hat sich das anscheinend erledigt, dann setzt euch doch gern wieder zurück. Weil er kann nicht dieses, inivproblem erkennen. Nee, du darfst nicht einmal eingreifen. Nee, nee, also wenn du Gott spielen willst, dann spiel wieder Gott. Dann kannst du dich dann aufhören, dann kannst du dich nicht versauern lassen, wenn du der Marionettenspieler des Abends sein willst. Oh Gott, im Himmel ist das unangenehm. Das sind so Angebote, die man schlecht ab... Man kann die vor allem auch nicht ablehnen, du kannst nicht sagen, nee, ist schon okay, weil es stört ja anscheinend jemanden oder es ist jemandem aufgefallen. Ach, Mann, das ist so, also das ist so nah an Gewalt einfach. Vor allem, ich bin ehrlich gesagt bei diesen Kreuzgesprächen immer so, bin so von der Fear of Missing Out FOMO besessen. Genau, weil das andere Gespräch ist immer interessanter. Immer ins andere Gespräch reinhöre und
sofort so einem
Mensch werde, weil ich eigentlich dazu
höre, was gerade gesagt wird. Weil du zwei Gespräche
aufnimmst. Ja, genau.
Ich bin da nicht sehr gut darin, lauter
zu werden oder mein Gespräch durchzusetzen
oder sowas. Ich denke immer, ja, das ist doch eh spannender, was die
zu sagen haben. Schrecklich.
Ich gehe nicht mehr raus, leider. Es lohnt
sich einfach nicht mehr. Ich gehe nicht mehr raus. ich bleib drin. Es lohnt sich nicht. Ein Seinfeld-Quote, den ich neulich gesehen habe, das beste Date ist eigentlich ein Walking Date, das typische Walking Date, weil man der Person nicht in die Augen gucken muss. Es ist nicht so schlimm, was mache ich mit meinen Händen, wo gucke ich hin, wie gucke ich die ganze Zeit, genau, ausladende Gebewegungen, genau, einfach, und man muss sich nicht angucken, das ist total cool, und dann sagt Elaine, ja, das ist das, the next coolest thing to being alone. Ja, und da hat sie recht, also das ist, das ist wirklich das eine Date, was okay ist. Die Frage ist nur, wo geht man hin? Ne, wie ist das Ziel? Also ist es wirklich einfach so, lassen wir spazieren gehen, aber ich kenne mich nicht so gut aus und man landet irgendwo. Der Exit ist scheisse, der Exit ist bei sowas immer scheisse, das muss man wirklich auch abwägen. Naja, bis zur nächsten Bushaltestelle und dann sagen, so, hier ist meine Haltestelle, ciao. Hier ist meine Haltestelle. Ja, hier ist meine Haltestelle. Was meinst du mit deiner Haltestelle? Weiß ich nicht, aber einfach so, so, hier ist meine Haltestelle, war schön, tschüss. Da musst du vorher gut den Weg planen. Soll ich den Uber rufen? Die Chance aber, dass quasi ein Exitpoint kommt, genau dann, wenn du ihn brauchst, nämlich kein Interesse von dir aus, von ihr aus oder das Gespräch flaut ab, es ist aber eigentlich cool, aber du würdest gerne an einem Highpoint rausgehen, ist natürlich im Restaurant oder im Café immer einfach. Dann beendest du einfach dann das Date und sagst, il conto per favore. Genau. Und das Ganze ist zu Ende. Si. Aber das machst du natürlich nicht, auf einem Walking-Date kannst du es natürlich nicht. Du kannst niemals ein Gespräch so gut planen oder so was. Du müsstest dir vielleicht davor in der Stadt strategische Punkte suchen,
wo wie so eine Art Keil in der Mitte der Strasse ist,
wo du links davon vorbeigehen kannst, wo sie gar nicht anders kann,
als rechts zu laufen, und dann verliert man sich einfach.
Ich habe dich nicht mehr gefunden. Ja, komisch.
Und dann ist man einfach weg. Und dann muss man entweder schnell wegrennen oder sich irgendwo verstecken. Und dann ist es auch mysteriös so, auch ein cooler Abschluss für ein Date ist so ein, er war einfach weg. Das ist mir immer passiert bei, ich bin mit Leuten zum Flughafen gelaufen in Berlin-Tegel, das war glaube ich nach der Funkfeier, wo wir noch von guter Arbeit waren. Und wir waren zu dritt dann zu diesem Flughafen gelaufen und irgendwie sind wir von einem Fussweg abgekommen und waren plötzlich, ich sag mal, es war keine Autobahn, aber schon so eine krasse Schnellstrasse, wo wir plötzlich uns wiederfanden auf der Beschleunigungsspur dieser Schnellstrasse. Und wir hatten alle so lächerliche Rücksäcke auf und waren so bepackt und wurden dann plötzlich so in, wir sind zur Karawane gelaufen, hintereinander weg, weil es davor schon so eng wurde, weil der Bürgersteig ausgelaufen ist, dann wurde er aber zu dieser Schnellstrasse irgendwie und dann wurden wir plötzlich viel schneller gelaufen und fanden uns plötzlich wieder auf dieser wie Autos, wir versuchen Autos zu emittieren und wurden plötzlich dieser Beschleunigungsspur schneller, um uns einzureihen, Blinker gesetzt. Aber es wurde so, da war so merkwürdig, plötzlich ist man da als Fußgänger so, man ist der Straßenordnung so unterwürfig verfallen. Das ist wie ein Stück Ast in einem Fluss. Und sowas müsste man eigentlich finden, dass man sich dann so gut verlieren kann. Oder so, man müsste halt auf den Flughafen gehen, und dann geht man selber so auf diese Fließbänder, diese Laufbänder und sie nicht so, man geht so ganz rechts, so dass sie nicht rauf kann und dann ist man eh schneller. Ja, und dann läuft sie los, rennt sie los langsam. Und dann läuft man einfach normal weiter und dann ist es schneller. Du kannst auch so vor ihr weglaufen, auch in der Innenstadt. Ich nicht. Ich bin nach fünf Minuten brechend zusammenröchend. Und ich brauche einfach die richtige Musik.
Es ist so essentiell für mich, welche Musik man beim Joggen hat.
Und ich habe eine coole, fetzige Playlist, aber wenn die nicht funktioniert, dann ist es einfach schlecht.
Darf ich Fragen stellen zu coolen, fetzigen Playlist? Nein.
Was für Songs sind denn da coolen, fetzigen Playlist?
Nein, da ist sowas drin wie, ähm, wie heißt der nochmal, der Dings, der mit der Gitarre, nicht Rodin Keaton, nee, nee, Ed Sheeran, aber die Fetzigen, aber wirklich die Drücker, die Drücker Tracks, wo du wirklich gedrückt wirst, das ist richtig gut, nee, da habe ich ein paar gute Tracks. Ich war noch in der Bahn und war sauer, wusste aber nicht genau, wie ich reagieren sollte und wollte dich da mal als Bahnkondisseur und spezieller Experte für Bahngeflogenheiten fragen, was ich da machen kann. Bei der Bahn ist es ja irgendwie so, dass die Leute, die die Fenster reingesetzt haben außen und die Leute, die die Plätze innen drin sich arrangiert haben, aneinander Sprachen, sagen wir mal, aneinander vorbeigearbeitet haben. Ja. Niemand hat darauf geachtet, dass die Fenster zum Sitz gehören. Übrigens bei Flugzeugen auch nicht. Da gibt es nämlich auch so Plätze, wo du entweder nur ein halbes Fenster hast oder gar keins. Ja, so die Säulenplätze, wo du dann direkt vor einer Säule sitzt. Ja, bei so Fenstern, die dann gegen so einen Sitz, und wenn du das man sieht es ja von außen nicht so gut. Wenn du von außen ins Flugzeug reingucken würdest, wäre einfach ein Riesensitz vor diesem Fenster. Also arbeiten diese Departments nicht zusammen? Oder muss quasi der Abstand so sein bei den Fenstern von Flugzeugen und bei der Bahn, dass man da auf keinen Rücksicht nehmen kann? Naja, viele Fragen, auf die will ich gar nicht hinaus. Führt aber dazu, dass man teilweise sich Riesenfenster teilt mit mehreren Menschen. Und ich hatte die Fenstermajorität. Okay. Ich hatte wirklich drei Viertel des Fensters. Ja. Und vor mir saß eine junge Frau und die hatte das andere Viertel des Fensters. Es schien die Sonne rein. Mag ich ganz gern, mag ich ganz gern. Sie zog brachial am Fenster und hat mir, und ich bin auch grösser als sie, hat es quasi als Blende genommen, damit sie im Schatten sitzt. Es gibt ja da diese Sonnenblende, die man von oben runterziehen kann für das gesamte Fenster, somit nicht nur für seinen eigenen Platz, sondern auch für andere in dem Fall dein. Sie zieht also für mich diese riesen Sonnenblende runter. Für sich. Denkt ja gar nicht hinten an mich. Ich sitze da aber so und sie kann noch drunter hingegucken. Für mich ist es nämlich echt, dass es nach draußen gucken zu können. Ich finde das ganz schön. Konnte ich dann nicht mehr, weil es bis nach unten ging. Und dann habe ich überlegt, was ich jetzt mache. Und ich habe so eine halbe Stunde gewartet und es dann wieder hoch gemacht. Oh, okay. Ja, an der Stelle würde ich, und das ist eine ganz, ganz wichtige Technik, die man oft im Leben braucht, und zwar Dinge extrem langsam zu tun.
Was ich in dem Moment mache, ist, ich stütze meinen linken Arm auf das Fenster, drücke meinen Finger unter die Blende und versuche wirklich...
Wie schnell nach der Handlung von ihr?
Sofort, sofort. Aber die Geschwindigkeit ist extrem gedrosselt. Also wir reden wirklich von ein Zentimeter pro Minute. Nein, merkt man nicht. Ich bin so gut darin. Ein Zentimeter pro Minute und du musst wirklich nur leichten Druck ausüben. Dass sie irgendwann rüber guckt und das Fenster ist wieder oben und sie denkt, wie ist das denn jetzt passiert? Genau. Ich habe das doch gerade erst runtergekommen. Niemand sagt dann, hey, jetzt zieh ich es nochmal runter. So, das ist zwar auch schon mal passiert, aber das wirklich erst nach einer Stunde oder so. Du drückst es ganz langsam wieder hoch, bis du es da, so was haben willst. Aber dein Leidensdruck ist so hoch. Ja, weil du bist halt jetzt eine halbe Stunde beschäftigt, langsam den Motor dieser Fensterblende zu spielen. Ja, dann ist es aber so, da musst du jetzt einfach durch. Das ist das Spiel, das wir spielen. Ich denke mir, wir haben keinen Augenkontakt. Eine soziale Interaktion wurde noch gar nicht so richtig established. Hast du denn sowas losgelassen wie so ein... Ich habe es einfach... Oder so ein... Och Gott! Och du liebes Lüschen! Da scheint einmal die Sonne! Er hat so ein Typ mit so einem Toast-Shirt gerufen, die ist Ruhe ab, Teichens wieder. Dann habe ich gesagt, oh Gott ey, Pedanto! Oh! Drachen gespielt. Nee, wirklich, und das ist ganz, ganz wichtig im Leben, Dinge ganz langsam machen zu können, damit es andere nicht merken. Okay, habe ich auch lange im Flugzeug diese Theorie immer gehabt, dass ich, weil ich finde es immer so unangenehm, quasi so ruckartig den Sitz zurückzumachen. Absolut, völlig das so möglich. Und dann habe ich meinen Daumen auf diesem sehr befriedigenden Metallnöppel gedrückt und langsam meinen Rücken. Auch ein tolles Bauchmuskeltraining übrigens, weil man sich nicht zurückfallen lassen darf. Man kann sich ja kurz nicht anlehnen, weil man nutzt das Anlehnen nur, um langsam zurückzukommen. Ich verstehe. Problem, diese ganzen Dinge, über die wir gerade sprechen, Sitz zurück machen oder Fenster hoch, diese Blende hoch machen in unseren deutschen Bahnzügen, Da sind ja keine übergangsfreien, ruckelfreien, super geösten Mechaniken. Das ist natürlich die grosse Kunst. Nein, sie wird neben sich sitzen und dann hat sie die ganze Zeit dieses Na, doch, sie wird das Wackeln spielen. Dann machst du es nicht langsam genug, du musst es wirklich so langsam machen. Das ist so die Geschwindigkeit, mit der ein Fingernagel wächst. Das merkst du nicht. Du merkst ja nicht, plötzlich ist ein Fingernagel da, sondern das ist unmerkbar, weil es so langsam ist. Bis die Sonne wieder blendet. Bei mir ist nämlich oft der Fall, bei mir ist nämlich oft der Fall, dass ich mir Abteile miete, und dann hast du also, äh, reservieren. Zugabteile. Zugabteil, und dann hast du ja so einen Tisch. Und dann kann es sein, dass jemand direkt dir gegenüber sitzt. Und viele Leute legen auf dem Tisch einfach Dinge, als wäre es ihr zu Hause, einfach legen da Dinge rauf. Und ich stelle dann mein Laptop auf die Seite und schiebe dann über die gesamte Fahrt langsam, aber sicher, alles mit konstantem Augenkontakt, dem alles wieder zurück. Pringlesdose, schön langsam, aber sicher. Und es ist wirklich so langsam, dass die Person es nicht merkt. Oder du kannst natürlich auch die Technik wählen, wenn der mal kurz wegguckt, dann mal so ein paar Zentimeter mehr. Und das ist halt die Technik, die man lernen muss. Wie dieses Squid Game Spiel. Ja, genau. Immer wenn er wegguckt. Wenn er guckt guckt und du machst, hast du verloren. Dann hast du verloren, dann musst du aussteigen.
Egal wo du bist, dann bist du in Hagen, dann lebst du ab jetzt in Hagen.
Das ist dein Schicksal.
Aber so musst du wirklich alles langsam machen.
Das ist die große Fähigkeit.
Probiert das mal, für Anfänger zum Beispiel kann ich gut empfehlen, Türklinken.
Versucht mal wirklich, eine Tür aufzumachen, und zwar so langsam, dass man da nichts hört und nichts macht. Und dann versucht die Tür aufzumachen, so langsam, dass man nichts hört. Für Sieg ist es ein sehr guter Mensch, dass die Erwachsenen der Erwachsenen der Erwachsenen der Erwachsenen der Erw. Nicht erschrecken. Ins Arbeitszimmer gehen, dass ihr dann plötzlich drin seid und dann plötzlich, ha ha, hier bin ich. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das, also, mach's doch mal mit Rollläden, mach's doch mal mit Galesin.
Das ist jetzt kein Beziehungstipp, es ist jetzt ein Bahntipp, aber versuchst mal Dinge ganz langsam zu machen.
Ja, ich finde Rollläden gut, um ihre Nachbarn zu verwirren.
Ja, Rollläden sind auch nicht schlecht.
Hä, die war doch gerade noch oben, die Roller da drüben.
Vor einer halben Stunde war die noch, ist doch so merkwürdig, Also ich verstehe schon, was du meinst, aber dieses Unmerkliche ...
Ich glaub nur, es klappt nicht. Es klappt nicht, weil es nicht reibungslos genug ist. Du bist nicht reibungslos genug. Wenn da zu viel Reibung ist, dann machst du was falsch. Du musst das richtig machen. Es ist alles machbar, es ist alles möglich. Was ich gemacht habe, ist relativ schnell wieder das nach oben gemacht. oben dann, weil ich fand es mega unangenehm, erst mal quasi etwas zu verspüren, was ich hier gerne anders hätte. Und dann habe ich gedacht, wenn ich aber jetzt wieder hoch mache, no chance, dass sie es wieder runter macht. Keine fucking Chance, weil stell dir mal vor, du machst etwas hoch, hinter dir macht jemand wieder runter. Ich würde einen Teufel tun, jemals nochmal das zu berühren, was da passiert. Oder ist es ein unendlicher Kampf, den du verlieren würdest? Ja, aber der unendliche Kampf, ich glaube, die meisten schrecken vor dem zurück. Ich ja selbst auch. Ich dachte mir, es ist halt ein bisschen wie Überreizen, so bei Skatspielen oder so Pokern. Ich habe nämlich gedacht, okay, weil ich auch mehr Fenster hatte als sie,
ich glaube, das spielte mich auch noch eine Rolle,
ich überreize jetzt mal ein bisschen und mache es wieder hoch.
Und wenn sie jetzt mehr soziale Karten in der Hand hat,
also mehr soziale Aggressionen ...
Du callst ihren Bluff sozusagen.
Genau, und ich habe dementsprechend gewonnen jetzt,
in diesem Augenblick.
Aber es hätte natürlich sein können,
dass jemand mit mehr sozialem Selbstbewusstsein auf der Hand ausgestattet ist und dann quasi wieder unvermacht. Und dann wäre ich ausgestiegen. Dann wäre ich sowas von raus gewesen. Da hätte er meinen Bluff gecallt, weil ich hätte nichts. Es gibt gar nichts. Nicht mein Pärchen, gar nichts. Sie denken nämlich, oh, hinter mir ist der selbstbewusst, dass der Typ unangenehm, mit dem jetzt mich zu streiten. Und er hätte sich umgeguckt, hätte ich da mit angsterfülltem Blick gesessen
und gehofft, dass ich ... Komplett Schweiss
gebadet, komplett einfarbiges T-Shirt.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, ich mach's hoch.
Ansonsten, was ich mir auch noch vorstellen könnte, wäre vielleicht
irgendwie so eine Art Unfall.
Also im Sinne von, ich hab immer
ein Beutel ...
Ja genau, entweder Niesen oder irgendwas
hoch auf die Gepäckablage
hiefen und auf dem Weg halt so das Fenster touchieren und so ausrollen und dann hoch und dann einfach gucken, dass es so bleibt. Moment, also du willst dein Rucksack, deine Idee, dein genialer Plan, dein Heistplan ist es, den Rucksack oben, der ja direkt über dir ist, an der Wand langzuschrabben. Genau, weil er so schwer ist. Oh nein! Also du musst ihn an der Wand langschrabben, nimmst dabei die ganze Jalousie mit, schiebst ihn oben an dein Gepäck, dann hast du ihn über dir. Ja. Hältst ihn quasi einfach nur hoch an diesem Punkt. Ja. Da bin ich gespannt, wie du das selbstbewusst hinbekommst, um dann so über die Kante, okay, super. Nur als Idee, nur als Idee
könnte man das versuchen. Das ist ein Brainstorming.
Im Ende, glaube ich,
braucht man auch mehrere Strategien, um da
richtig dagegen anzugehen. Ja.
Aber okay, dann vielen Dank
die Theorie des Langsammachen
war mir ein Begriff, aber ich soll es vielleicht
auch mal richtig versuchen.
Ich hatte auch ein Problem, machen wir so ein
Bahnspezial, aber ich hatte auch ein Problem. Und zwar Abteil und aka Podcast, Bahnspezial. Ruheabteil, Abteil, Ruhebereich, Abteil und eine Dame am Handy laut. So, und jetzt waren wir zu viert im Abteil und tatsächlich irgendwann greift einer der Mitfahrenden ein und sagt, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Not all heroes wear capes.
Nee, absolut, Entschuldigung, das ist ja der Ruhebereich, Sie dürfen ja nicht telefonieren, Sie super aggressiv, erlaube mich nicht voll und so, keine Ahnung, so. Aber das war der eine Punkt, weil ich habe die Frau schon gesehen und ich dachte mir, dass das wird wahrscheinlich nichts bringen nach meiner enormen Menschenkenntnis.
Aber er hat es versucht, super toll, nach meiner enormen Menschenkenntnis.
Aber er hat es versucht, super toll. Aber du sagst, not all heroes wear capes, was man auch leider sagen muss, not all heroes wear shoes. Weil er hatte meine Sympathie, weil er im Ruhebereich gesagt hat, sie soll nicht telefonieren, aber er hatte leider auch seine Schuhe ausgezogen. Und ich dachte, wäre das jetzt, um zu sagen, ja, okay, aber ... Not all heroes wear shoes. Aber können sie dann vielleicht auch ihre Schuhe anziehen, wenn wir schon eine offene Kritikrunde haben gerade? Nee, du weißt ... Nee, was, woran du jetzt ... Nee, nee, nee, du denkst falsch, weil bei solchen offenen Kritikruünden erstmal was Positives sagen. Also, dann müsste man jetzt problematisch bei dem Ruheabteil, müsste man dann erflüstern. Das heißt, du musst sagen, so sorry, also erstmal vielen, vielen Dank, dass sie gerade was gesagt haben. Ich finde, das ist wichtig einfach, dass der Ruhebereich auch geärbt wird. Die Sandwich- Sandwich-Taktik, weil du musst nämlich erst mit etwas Positivem reingehen, also musst du sagen, mehr gut, vielen Dank, ich hätte diese Sozialcourage nicht gehabt, aber es ist super wichtig. Ach, natürlich, das ist doch kein Problem. Der Ruhebereich lebt von Leuten wie Ihnen. Danke. On a different note, ich finde es unhygienisch und nicht sehr appetitlich und schön, dass Sie jetzt die Schuhe ausgezogen haben. Wir sind ja hier auch immer teil, es ist begrenzt viel Platz. Ich finde es super schön, wenn Sie die Schuhe anziehen. Ach so, aber hier steht ja nichts von, dass man die Schuhe nicht ausziehen darf, weil hier steht ja extra, man darf nicht telefonieren. Das darf man schon machen, es ist mehr so eine gesellschaftliche Gepflogenheit. Na ja, wir dem auch so, vielen Dank nochmal dafür, dass Sie gerade, weißt du, Sandwich Note, Sandwich. Ja, ja. Aber du kannst aber ..., ja, aber du kannst aber, Moment, Sandwich heißt aber auch nicht, ich kenne es als die Misschnittentaktik, du kannst aber nicht dasselbe Kompliment am Ende nochmal bringen. Ja, Problem ist, du hast so wenig. Ich dachte, du musst zwei unterschiedliche Sachen sagen. Ja, stimmt schon, weil wir hatten jetzt so wenig mit ihm, du kannst sagen, ich blieb ihr Shirt, ich mag die Deutsche Telekom auch. Ich mag ihr Shirt an ihnen, ja? Nur um das mal gesagt zu haben. Ja, es war unangenehm und ich habe da nichts gesagt, weil du hast wenig juristische Grundlage für Schuhverlust in der Situation. Schuh und Socken übrigens, auch nochmal an der Stelle, beides ausgezogen, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Ich bin auf Ihrer Seite, lieber telefonieren fast. Ja, aber ich sass da vor so zwei Brandherden und ich dachte mir, was... Dritter Mann? Wer war der dritte? Nett, am Handy getippt und sie hat, also die zweite Frau hat dann auch denjenigen unterstützt und meinte, ja, übrigens das ist auch das Ruheabteil hier. Weil er meinte nur so, Entschuldigung, können Sie bitte leise sein und dann meinte sie nur so, ja, das ist übrigens auch der Ruhebereich hier. Und dann war auch so ein bisschen von der Gruppendynamik ein bisschen ich an der Reihe.
Weil das war so der Uhrzeigersinn, so schön, seien Sie leise, ist ja auch der Ruhebereich und ich, können Sie Ihre Schuhe anziehen?
Ja, ganz, nee, hat nicht funktioniert. Oder was eine andere Kommunikationstaktik ist, die ich noch kenne, immer super unangenehm, wenn es in der Uni mal Probleme gab zwischen Leuten oder sowas, in so Kreativprojekten oder sowas haben wir gelernt. Man soll erst sagen, was das Lieblingsereignis war oder was das Beste war, was man zusammen schon geschafft hat, dann sagen, was schon sehr gut läuft, dann sagen, was nicht gut läuft. Also so ein klassischer Verfall. Und dann zum Abschnitt wieder sagen, wie wir uns wünschen, wie wir es dann konkret besser machen könnten. Und ich fände es so gut, wenn sie sagt, können Sie bitte aufhören, Sie zu lüften, eine andere Frau sagt, nee, genau, ist ja Ruheabteil. Und du sagst, also erst mal fand ich es total schön, wie wir in Hagen gemeinsam zusammengekommen sind. Das war eigentlich der beste Moment. Dass Sie ihnen geholfen haben mit dem schweren Koffer irgendwie hochgestellt. Wir gemeinsam gesagt haben, wollen wir die Blende aufmachen. Alle waren sich einig. Das war total super. Dann, was nicht so gut läuft, finde ich, sie telefonieren die ganze Zeit und sie tragen keine Schuhe, zudem keine Socken. Auf keine Schuhe können die mich einigen, die Sockenprobleme finde ich ein bisschen problematisch. Naja, wie ich finde, was wir in Zukunft besser machen könnten, ist offenere Kommunikationskultur, also besser sprechen, gemeinsam vielleicht auch sagen, dass alle nochmal sagen, was das schönste Ereignis ist, dass ich nicht der einzige bin, der die positiven Ereignisse herausstellt. Ey, laber mich nicht voll, ey! Ja, dankeschön, die Kritik kommt an. Wie kommt die Kritik an? Nee, ich wollte nur sagen, dass ich sie aufgefasst habe. Dann würde ich mir wünschen, dass wir alle ein bisschen mehr Rücksicht aufeinander nehmen würden. Und nur weil sie jetzt die Schuhe ausziehen wollen, sich damit wohler fühlen, drei Leute hier sich im Abteil vielleicht nicht damit wohler fühlen. Also finde ich schön, wenn wir aufeinander mehr Rücksicht nehmen würden. Danke. Und alle setzen die Kopfhörer wieder auf. Ja. Und es geht zwei Stunden lang weiter. Weil das war dann schon auch richtig unangenehm, weil nach diesem Vorfall, diesem, können Sie bitte leise sein, ey, laber mich nicht voll, ging die Zugfahrt noch zwei Stunden in der gleichen Konstellation weiter. In der nichts gesagt wird. Wie so denn konkret reagiert, aber da muss man es nämlich, ich finde dann fast die Pflicht, es eskalieren zu lassen. Weil dann einfach einzuknicken, nach laber mich nicht voll zu sagen, okay, wieder am Handy zu sitzen, wie merkwürdig. Ja, aber die meisten Leute haben nicht das Momentum, dann zu eskalieren. Wahrscheinlich dachte der sich zehn Minuten später auch, hätte ich mal eskaliert, aber du kannst ja dann nicht wieder zurückkommen nach zehn Minuten. Übrigens nochmal dazu dazu, dass sie telefoniert haben. Geht nicht. Und dann sitzt sie zwei Stunden lang mit einer offenen Aggression und Feindschaft, die einfach ist in dem Raum. Die wäre in mir an deiner Stelle viel höher als offensichtlich in dem Mann, der was gesagt hat. Weil er ja gesagt hat, schon können Sie auf uns telefonieren, sie sagt, laber mich nicht voll, er sagt,
okay, widmet sich wieder Angry Birds.
Es war schon so ein bisschen,
warum sind Sie denn jetzt so unnöchlich,
man kann doch mal miteinander reden und so,
aber und dann sie auch nur wieder, ja, laber mich
nicht voll.
Sie haben jetzt das gleiche
Argument zweimal.
Das ist das Problem,
weil die eine Partei hat sich nicht an rhetorische Regeln gehalten und hat einfach ihr Ausgangsargument laber mich nicht voll einfach nochmal genannt. Also meine Kommunikationstaktik. Es funktioniert nur, wenn beide nach den Regeln spielen. Genau, meine positiv, positiv, was können wir besser machen, was ist das beste Ereignis und so funktioniert halt nur, wenn alle sich daran halten. Ist mega unangenehm, wenn du diese Vorträge hältst und alle drei sagen, Alter, laber mich nicht voll. Ja, Toast, Chard. Ja, das war eine schwierige Situation. Unangenehm. Unangenehm. Also was lernen wir daraus? Nichts sagen. Oder keine Bahn mehr fahren. Schön in den Verbrenner einsteigen. Und langsam, Dinge langsam machen, ganz langsam. Nicht mit der Brechstange, nicht
sondern ganz langsam.
Ganz langsam.
Wobei ich mit meiner Taktik jetzt gut gefahren bin, mit meiner Arschloch,
ich mach's wieder Hochtaktik.
Nochmal, bevor ich wieder die ganzen Mails bekomme, dass ich ein Arschloch
bin, ich hatte wirklich sehr
viel Teil des Fensters, also so
ich hatte ein Riesenfenster vor mir
und sie war kaum daran beteiligt.
Sie hätte sich einfach auf einen anderen Platz setzen können, neben ihr der Freifahr und hätte die Sonne nicht mehr gehabt. Zum Beispiel, nur als kleiner Vorschlag. Aber ich denke mir auch immer so, wer diesen ICE-Design, der denkt sich doch, nee, weißt du, hier machen wir mal so ein kleines soziales Spiel rein, denn die Blenden sind nämlich so groß, dass die über mehrere Sitze reichen und die müssen sich nonverbal einigen, wie tief das geht. Viel Spaß damit. Es sind doch wirklich einfach soziale Teufel, die da agieren. Warum baut man das denn so? Ich bin mal in Köln in der U-Bahn gewesen und dann ist mein Held eingestiegen, also not wearing a cape, but wearing shoes, good shoes, cool shoes.
Das ist ein älterer Mann, so ganz lange Haare und dann plötzlich hat die Bahn irgendwo gehalten, U-Bahn, er ist eingestiegen und hat erstmal wütend alle Fenster aufgemacht. Er ist eingestiegen und hat gesagt, alle Fenster aufgerissen, da sind da oben diese Klappfenster. Und ich habe mir das gedacht, ich würde mich gerne mal irgendwo so zu Hause fühlen, wie er in der öffentlichen Bahn, dem öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Dem gehört dieses Abteil jetzt. Aber es ist ja der öffentliche Nahverkehr. Es ist unser, es ist auch meiner, es ist deiner. Unser Nahverkehr. Aber hauptsächlich seiner auch. Ja, aber er hat es zu seinem gemacht. Und ich finde, genau so sollte man eigentlich, ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt, vielleicht weil es zu teuer ist oder was auch immer, aber man nimmt es nicht so richtig, als dass die Stadt stellt, die das als Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung war. Ja, es ist unsers. Es ist eigentlich auch ein bisschen unsers. Du solltest eigentlich in so ein Abteil gehen und erstmal wirklich Schalosien rauf, runter, Gepäck runter, Gepäck hochheben und wirklich einfach mal Ansagen machen, einfach mal du nimm mal die Beine da runter, du setz dich mal da um, wollt ihr beiden euch nicht umsetzen, du stell den Scheiss mal hoch hier, du zieh das da runter, so einfach hier, du setz dich mal anders hin und du hör auf zu telefonieren, so, bonjourno. So, bonjourno, jetzt war ja immer ein Kaminer. Aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Willen auch jemanden geist, ich habe was da. Einfach so eine Packung, Flutschfinger dabei haben. Auch einfach was zurückgeben. Das ist, glaube ich, vielleicht auch. Oder Schuhe ausziehen und Schlappen anziehen. Nee, nicht die Schuhe ausziehen. Einfach vielleicht die Schuhe anhalten. Wie wäre es damit? Wäre das eine Lösung? Ich dachte gerade, wenn man sich vor Hause fühlt. Könnten wir uns darauf einigen? Soll ich immer so eine Mathe, so eine Fussmathe mitgebracht, lege ich sie hin. Lege ich jetzt hier vor die Türen. Aber das fand ich so gut. Weil das ist eigentlich, das ist eine Mindset, was mir total gefällt. Quasi so, also wenn alle sich so verhalten, mega weird, schon mal vor, danach käme ein ähnlicher Mensch rein. Und macht alles wieder zu. Und macht die alle wieder zu. Das wäre der Kampf der Titanen einfach. In meinem Kopf sieht der gerade genau aus wie das Gegenteil. Der hat natürlich so lange helle Haare, da kommt so ein Typ mit so langen dunklen Haaren ein, hat so inverted man. Aber mit dem gleichen Grunzen, auch mit diesem Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, wäre dann mal ein Kampf. Ja, die beiden. Aber das fand ich nicht so schlecht, diese Haltung, die wünscht man sich ja eigentlich ein bisschen in sich selbst, dass man, weil ich bin ja so eher, möglichst wenig berühren, möglichst schnell wieder aussteigen, möglichst wenig Luft inhalieren, von diesem, auch gerade im Sommer eher meiden, wenn die Bahnen zu voll sind und so was und dann lieber Fahrrad fahren.
Aber das ist natürlich, wenn du so ein
Mindset hast, dieses, ich mache jetzt erst mal
die Fenster auf, weil das ist meine Bahn
und das ist mein Klima, da finde ich das
eigentlich nicht so schlecht. Ich finde das richtig gut.
Weil das macht, glaube ich, was mit dir.
Wir müssten eigentlich mal so ein extrovertiert
Training machen, so ein richtig krasser extrovertierter Typ
und dann mal so Aufgaben im Alltag.
Geh jetzt mal in die U-Bahn und mach mal alle Fenster zu Einfach so mal raus aus seiner Kampfhazorn. Wirklich so ein ... so ein Training einfach. Ich glaube, ich würde das abbrechen. Da möchte ich mal mit dir reden drüber, über extrovertiert, introvertiert. Weil ich glaub, ich hab entweder Definitionen in meinem Kopf, die zu updaten sind oder schlicht falsch sind. Definieren wir für mich extrovertiert, weil ich glaube, dass in mir ein Kampf tobt. Oh, spannend, zwischen schwarzhaarig und blond. Zwischen, ich mache die Fenster auf und ich fasse hier gar nichts an und sage auch nichts. Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es viele verschiedene Definitionen, die sich wahrscheinlich auch widersprechen, aber die, die ich ganz gut finde, ist, dass bei Introvertierten kosten soziale Interaktionen Energie
und bei Extrovertierten, die kriegen durch soziale Interaktionen Energie. Also die sagen nach dem Feierabend, jetzt muss ich mit Freunden treffen und noch was trinken, dadurch regenerieren die und Introvertierte sagen, oh nee, jetzt war ich irgendwie einmal mit Freunden weg, jetzt brauche ich zwei Wochen Urlaub und sehe gar niemanden mehr. So, ist das natürlich nicht auf alles zu übertragen. Nee, vor allem, was ist das für eine Batterie, die quasi sich aufgeladen wird durch Alleinsein, warum sollte die überhaupt wieder unter Leute gehen? Weil das, da habe ich nämlich auch. Das ist eine gute Frage, die sich wahrscheinlich jeder Introvertierte irgendwann mal stellt, aber zu gewissen Dingen braucht man dann schon einen zwischenmenschlichen Kontakt. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass Introvertierte den zwischenmenschlichen Kontakt nicht auch genießen können, nur ist es halt einfach kräftezehrender. Es ist halt einfach, man kann halt nicht so viel davon machen. So, wenn du auf den Berg steigst, ist es auch anstrengend, das kannst du auch nicht jeden Tag machen. Aber du machst es ja trotzdem, weil es ja an sich schon schön. Und mit den richtigen Leuten ist es ja auch in Ordnung. Aber es kostet halt Energie. Das ist dann halt der vielleicht, der auf der Party eine Stunde Spaß hat und dann aber nach Hause geht. Wogegen der Extrovertierte bleibt bis fünf Uhr nachts und der Extrovertierte liegt halt im Bett zu Hause. Aber hatte trotzdem einen schönen Abend. Ich habe mein Gefühl, ich habe zwei Systeme in mir, und die wechseln sich ab, wenn das eine in Kraft getreten ist.
Beispiel, wenn ich unter Leuten war, muss ich danach meine Energie wieder aufladen und durch alleine sein. Und wenn die wieder aufgeladen ist, kippt es wieder um, so ein Kippschalter. Und dann brauchst du wieder den Kontakt. Genau, brauche ich dann aber schnell wieder Kontakt, sonst werde ich unglücklich. Und habe das Gefühl, dass sich dann die Batterie wieder auflädt. Und dann macht es wieder klack und ich bin wieder im anderen System drin. Weil ich finde es nämlich fast so einfach, sich quasi dem zu unterwerfen und zu sagen. Nee, deswegen gibt es ja auch drei Kategorien. Es gibt ja introvertiert, extrovertiert und Stefan. Also es gibt ja drei Möglichkeiten. Die Special Snowflake. Genau. Und du bist halt dann wahrscheinlich eher ein Stefan. Das kann dann halt gut sein, dass du da in die Kategorie reinfällst. Na ja, weiß ich jetzt. Du bist halt der einzige Mensch, der nicht in diese Kategorisierung reinfällt. Aber ist das in Ordnung? Ist doch in Ordnung. Keine so viele Kategorien aufmachen, wie wir, wir haben doch genug Ordner da. Ist doch kein Problem. Ich glaube, dann bin ich ein Stefan. Also wenn man jetzt so überlegt. Die Vermutung hatte ich schon lange, aber jetzt bewahrheitet sie sich. Du bist ein Stefan. Dann würde ich fast sagen, aber na gut, also gibt es solche Teufelhage, aber dann glaube ich, bin ich eher ein Stefan. Okay, finde ich gut. Interessant, ja gut, mit dir lernen wir noch eine Menge. Gerne, du, ich kann dir Sachen erklären. Weil ich finde zum Beispiel keine introvertierte Entscheidung per se, wie man das Fenster wieder hochmacht. Also eine sehr, sehr schöne Definition finde ich auch von den Drinnis, da geht es ja auch um Introvertierte. Und die haben auch eine sehr schöne Formulierung gefunden mit, Introvertierte, wollen den Betriebsablauf nicht stören.
Die wollen nicht durch ihre eigene Anwesenheit irgendwas verändern oder stören. Die würden nicht auf Probleme hinweisen oder irgendwas, wenn dadurch Aufmerksamkeit auf sie selber rückt. Und sie wollen nicht jetzt ein großes Spektakel um diese Blende machen, sondern lieber ihre eigenen Bedürfnisse zurückstecken. So, die würden, wenn ihnen im Supermarkt ein Glas Honig runterfällt, würden sie das niemandem sagen, weil sie wollen jetzt nicht, dass da jetzt aufruft wird. Aber dann gibt es keine Unterschiede zwischen Social Awkwardness und Introvertis. Ja, das ist recht nah dran. Ja, das weiß ich nicht, weil ich glaube nämlich nicht, weil das ist mir alles eigentlich ein bisschen so einfach, weil ich kenne sehr viele exklusivierte Menschen, die den Betriebsoblauf auch nicht stören wollen. Ist ja auch die Frage, wie sehr, was macht es mit dir, wenn du den nicht störst? Also wie sehr stört dich dein eigenes Zurückstecken? Ich würde behaupten, exklarierte Menschen wenig, exklarierte Menschen... Also weniger als die Alternative. Ein Beispiel, ich stand an der Supermarktkasse und eine ältere Frau kam mit dem Selbstbewusstsein, das nur alte Menschen haben, hat sich straight vorgedrängelt, hat sich direkt vor mich gestellt, aber nicht mit einem irgendwie darf ich, kann ich, sondern einfach nö, hier bin ich jetzt. So, und ich fand das fast schon wieder okay einfach. Es war einfach so, ich bin alt, mir ist alles scheissegal, du hast Zeit, ich habe noch eine Woche zu leben, ich bin jetzt hier. So, wunderbar. Und für mich war das, natürlich sage ich nichts. Aber bei mir ist es halt so unvorhersehbar, ganz kurz Einschub, es ist komplett unvorhersehbar, jetzt gerade für mich hier am Tisch zu sitzen und zu entscheiden, zu sagen, wie ich dann reagieren würde. So viele Sachen, weil ich könnte beides machen. Es gibt Tage, an denen ich das nicht ansprechen würde, weil ich entweder Zeit habe oder gut gelaunt bin oder sowas. Aber das sind alles Faktoren, die man gar nicht einschließt. Man sagt ja, entweder ich bin extrovertiert oder introvertiert und die reagieren so, die reagieren immer so. Bei mir ist es komplett unvorhersehbar und ich glaube, das geht den meisten so, dass wenn du jetzt wahnsinnig viel Stress hättest und ich schon schlecht gelaunt bist und gerade so ein Fuck it, ich seh die Indie wieder Mode hast im Kopf, dann wahrscheinlich was sagen würde. Allein die Vorstellung, das anzusprechen, um dann noch mehrere Minuten mit ihr in derselben Schlange zu stehen, auf gar keinen Fall. Was ist passiert? Ich stand an der rechten Kasse, rechte Schlange, sie kommt einfach rein, drängelt sich direkt vor mir. Auf der linken Schlange stand auf gleicher Höhe eine junge Frau, die das gesehen hat und die Dame angesprochen hat und gesagt hat, Entschuldigung, Sie haben sie jetzt direkt hier vor dem jungen Mann hier gedrängelt. Und ich nur so, wow, einfach nur so, alles okay, alles okay. Die ist auf dem anderen Spektrum. Die ist komplett raus. Sie spricht selbst Dinge an, die selbst sie nicht betreffen. Aber ist auch einfacher.
Nicht betroffen.
Und jetzt plötzlich zieht sie die Aufmerksamkeit auf mich und deutet so auf mich und sagt, sie haben sich vor diesen jungen Mann gedrängelt. Und nicht nur so, ich bin nicht anwesend. Bist du noch der junge Mann? Ja, hat sie gesagt zumindest. Und ich war so, alles okay, kein Problem, super, okay. Und es war richtig unangenehm, weil jetzt auf diesen, weil jetzt der Betriebsablauf gestört wurde. Plötzlich war dieses Problem im Raum und ich war mitverantwortlich, wurde da reingezogen und das war ganz schrecklich. Ganz schrecklich, weil vor allem nicht nur jetzt Aufmerksamkeit auf mich gezogen wurde, sondern auch Aufmerksamkeit darauf gezogen wurde, dass ich nichts gesagt habe, dass ich sozusagen nicht selber für meine Ungerechtigkeit ein, sondern ich brauche jetzt jemand anderen, der sagt, guck mal, Sie haben jetzt den hier richtig schlecht behandelt und ich so, ich werde gerne schlecht behandelt, völlig in Ordnung, völlig gut. Dein Sozialanwalt kämpft ja auf verlorenen Posten, wenn der Mandant sagt, ich habe nichts gesagt, ich habe keine Meinung dazu. Die andere Frau hätte erstmal zu mir kommen sollen und sagen, okay, wir machen das jetzt. Ich habe mir überlegt, ich habe folgende Strategie, fünf Punkte Plan, ich werde die Frau anklagen vor dem obersten Gericht und ich möchte, dass sie folgendes sagen. Kasse drei, Oberstgericht meinend Kasse drei, ja, ich verstehe das. Nee, es gab keine Strategie zwischen uns, sondern einfach direkt reingeworfen. Und ich habe dann gesagt, nee, nee, schon okay, alles in Ordnung. Und dann standen wir wieder mehrere Minuten lang in genau dieser Konstellation da und sind nebeneinander hergeschaffelt mit diesem, sie denkt sich, was für ein Vollidiot, kämpft nicht mal dafür, dass sie ungerecht behandelt wurde. Ich stand da völlig unangenehm. Der alten Frau war scheißegal. Die war für mich der Held in der Geschichte. Der war alles völlig einfach so, laber mich nicht voll. Das sind am Ende einfach immer die Gewinner in sozialen Situationen. Wo ist sie als junge Frau gestartet? Das finde ich auch spannend. Wo kommt sie her? Wie hätte sie damals reagiert, wenn das passiert wäre? In deinem Alter zum Beispiel? Und ist das so eine Alters, sagen wir mal, ist ja keine, ist ja, wenn du das noch extra, ist das eine andere Kategorie. Alt. Ignoranz. Einfach alt. Mir ist alles völlig egal. Ich denke gar nicht in diesen Kategorien, weil existiere nur ich. So, wenn die rückwärts aus der Einfahrt fährt, die schaut nicht mehr zurück. Ich gucke, es ist einfach egal. Sie denkt, ich existiere und das noch für ein paar Jahre. In der Zeit mache ich, was ich will. Ich habe, I earned my right. Aber das ist, ich finde es ziemlich spannend. Naja, ich wollte nur diese Frage stellen, weil ich glaube, also in mir tobt aktuell dieser Kampf in der Mitte um viele Kämpfe. Und ich habe, das ist das Jahr 2022, habe ich jetzt als das große Ambivalenzjahr ausgerufen. Okay, das Jahr der inneren Kämpfe? Nein, die Kämpfe kenne ich schon sehr lange in mir, seit ich denken kann und reflektiere. Ich habe nur nie mit der Ambivalenz leben können und immer versucht, quasi ein Ergebnis, ein kleines Ergebnis zu kommen. 2022 habe ich jetzt gerade schon als das grosse, es ist völlig okay, dass Kämpfe mit Toben ja ausgerufen. Also die Konfliktparteien lassen die, senken die Waffen? Nee, nee, nee, es wird weiter gekämpft. Aber ich bin komplett okay damit, dass es kein Ergebnis ist. Okay, du hoffst nicht mehr auf den Ausgang. Ich komme mit der Komplexität des Seins besser klar, als noch letztes Jahr. Okay, das ist doch super, das ist doch schön. Und neulich wurde ich einmal als Herr bezeichnet, was mich ärgere, ich mag das ja sehr, wenn fremde Menschen über einen reden und ich bin oft der junge Mann, wie du, neulich war ich einmal, lass den Herrn doch mal vorbei, das fand ich so schwierig, da hat es langsam gekippt, danach ist aber was passiert, da hat nämlich ein kleiner Junge gesagt, oh der Junge vor uns hatte aber so einen QR-Code, da war ich der Typ mit dem QR-Code und da war ich der Junge. Oh, okay. Das heißt, in dieser Woche ist alles passiert, ich war der junge Mann, Herr und der Junge. Grosse Bandbreite. Ja, also es war alles da drin. Sehr, sehr schön, ich freue mich sehr darauf, den jungen Herrn hier nächste Woche wieder begrüßen zu dürfen, wenn es weitergeht mit das Podcast Uwe. Es war nicht die letzte Folge heute, wir haben uns dazu entschieden, noch eine weitere Folge zu machen, mindestens.
Wir machen mindestens noch eine weitere und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Schauen wir mal. Nächste Woche seid wieder mit dabei, bis dahin, heben wir ab!
It's a worst bird production. Action. Ja, kannst du die Musik bitte ausmachen? Ja, sorry. Müssen wir sagen, dass wir 2024 den Deutschen Podcastpreis gewonnen haben?
Auf jeden Fall, wir müssen ganz oft auch unseren Namen sagen,
Wild und Fremd, Wild und Fremd, Wild und Fremd, damit die Leute unbedingt draufklicken.
Glaubst du wirklich, dass es jetzt irgendwelche Leute hören und extra noch Wild und Fremd googeln?
Mal schauen.